bioti prinzlo gave us a rare look at her
and adam levine's daughter
gio the 32 year old model was
celebrating their youngest daughter's
birthday on tuesday
when she posted this fun selfie to her
instagram
and added a cute l filter across their
faces
she captioned the pic quote my bestie
turned three
it was beautiful yeah really cool biati
and the maroon 5
front men seldom share photos of g.o or
their four-year-old daughter dusty rose
i was always a huge fan last april adam
stopped by howard stern's siriusxm show
where he revealed biati is quote not
ready to expand their family
just yet he added quote we're good we've
got two kids
adam yeah he wants like five yeah he
wins five
during an appearance on the ellen
degeneres show the year before
biatti joked that she and adam haven't
always seen eye to eye
on just how big their family could get i
thought i wanted
five but now i think maybe like three
or four will be good you're backing up
i'm backing just just by one
yeah you know adam can't have everything
no he can't
he has everything i'm carrying them yeah
adam chatted with et in 2018 and
revealed how fatherhood
changed the way he looked at things on
the voice do you go into mama and papa
bear mode with your contestants
well i think the difference for me was
that i wasn't a parent before
i did it and alicia was and you know so
i was a kid i mean this was a long time
ago i've been doing this
forever um i wasn't a parent i didn't
have a wife i was just a loose cannon
living in l.a being crazy so now
i think that through the voice for sure
for sure for me
was one of the first times i ever had i
guess
um a platform that i could help people
out with or like even be that play a
role at all as like a mentor a
mentorship
really right so yes it did help me
indirectly in
what inevitably became being a parent
for sure that's
cool like you realize you have things
you can share with other people
it's not so much paternal as it is just
like you realize your whole life you've
lived up to this point you now have
things you can reflect on and help
people that are coming up with
that's cool and i think that for sure
helps with parenting somehow you love
being a girl dad
yeah i didn't think i was going to but i
love it yeah yeah i always knew it was
gonna be
the way i knew i was having girls right
i just knew it yes
you